mon pc mon p 30 pro mon pc prend
complètement le contrôle regardez là
avec ma fille d'origine avis et ça prend
totalement le contrôle de mon p 30 pro
je navigue jouve les à deux jeunes
avides directement depuis mon pc en gros
je fais exactement ce que je veux de mon
smartphone depuis mon pc et je vous ai
prié comment ça marche abaca je ne m'en
plains pas nos gars là comment est ce
que j'arrive à piloter mon smartphone
depuis mon pc alors ici il n'ya pas de
piratage ya pas d'astuce complètement
dingue
il s'y est juste une super compatibilité
entre un produit et un deuxième s'est
produit sont tous les deux de la marque
huawei donne dans le mille ses écrits
ici en plein milieu avec le nouveau
macbook des 15 pouces qui est d'être
présente et ordinateurs que d'être sorti
ya pas très longtemps et que vous pouvez
précommander dès maintenant d'ailleurs
si vous intéresse vous aimez les liens
en bas dans la description et bien vous
pouvez venir piloter très facilement
votre smartphone hors pâte n'importe
quel smartphone eu effectivement des
smartphones de huawei vous avez de
grosses possibilités
je vais tout vous expliquer je vous
montrer comment ça marche je veux sûr
profité pour présenter ce nouvel
ordinateur qui est vachement bien et en
plus de ça puisque vous êtes chansons
aujourd'hui nous offre le vôtre ici là
c'est le modèle 15 pouces moi je vous
offre le modèle 14 pouces d ordi qui
sont vachement cool je vais tout vous
expliquer tout vous détailler vous allez
voir c'est extrêmement ça pour
participer vous avez un lien en bas dans
la description et on a vite vous n'allez
pas être déçus voici donc la machine qui
vous permet de piloter votre smartphone
huawei macbook des 15 très cool en garde
est un ordinateur 15 pouces c'est tout
nouveau modèle vous avez un petit
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui est
situé juste ici vous posez votre doigt
sa déverrouille extrêmement facilement
point d'écrans tactiles ici vous allez
venir naviguer directement avec votre
petit trackpad
on a ici un écran de 15,6 pouces et une
dali ps 16 9ème 1920 par 1080 qui
occupent 87
on sent de la face avant en écran qu est
certifié lutter contre la lumière bleue
avec des bancs extrêmement fins de 5 3
mm ici la webcam a été supprimée bus qui
a été intégré ici d'un clavier entre la
touche f6 ailleurs sept points positifs
votre vie privée est complètement
respecté points négatifs vous êtes
filmés par en dessous on vole de sovac
nez et si vous avez les poils qui
dépassent
on risque de les voir et c'est une
petite faute km2
1 mégapixels qui permet de filmer en
720p pour l'audio parleurs 2 x 2 watts 2
micros et une prise jack vont dans le
sens de la qualité sonore fait plutôt
bien taf on n'a pas un son qui est
complètement malade pousse à fond on n'a
pas un volume hyper hyper hyper dingue
les haut parleurs situés parle de sous
c'est un soft est plutôt grave médium ne
qui fera taf
vu la configuration de cette bécane en
connectique on va avoir un usb c'est un
usb 3.0 hdmi 2 usb 2.0 et une prise jack
on a un clavier avec une course un peu
longue mais qui fait le taf on a un
trackpad qui est pas trop grand mais pas
trop petit non plus côté performances on
aime déraisonne 5 3500 eu la carte
graphique c'est une radio vega 8
on a 8 gigas de ram et 256 go de
stockage en ssd
l'autonomie est pas mal avec ce gros
bloc de charge de 65 watts
on a une batterie de 42 water est bien
évidemment l'autonomie va dépendre de
vous de vos usages
si vous demandez pas utiliser beaucoup
les performances de la machine devait
pouvoir garder quand même relativement
longtemps 6 7h 8h ça dépend vraiment de
vous ce que vous allez en faire sur un
usage courant vous comptez entre 5 à 6
heures mais dans l'absolu l'autonomie
est quand même relativement bien là
dessus très ce qui est très drôle c'est
que voix nous indique même vous pouvez
venir recharger votre smartphone avec
directement dessus vu que c'est l'usbc
vu que la prise là dessus pour la
recharger s'est lui élevé c'est donc
dans l'absolu pourquoi pas côté os 6 ans
windows dix familles on adoucit 5 pas de
wifi 6 on a du bluetooth 5.0 on a bien
évidemment du nfc
cette machine c'est un ordinateur milieu
de gamme on va pas avoir le max de
performance avec ses panneaux bientôt
vous utilisez pour les grosses party
gaming vous n'allez pas pouvoir utiliser
pour du gaming peut-être quelques petits
jeux qui ne [ __ ] pas plus que ça mais
si on regarde avec un équivalent intel
autres et ce en intel core i5
on a un truc qui est pas mal qui vous
permettra pas de faire du montage vidéo
permettra pas d'aller très très loin
retouche photo avec 8 gigas de ram
dévoué pouvoir utiliser au quotidien à
la maison pour faire du traitement de
texte de la prise de notes pour aller
travailler à la fac très facilement pour
regarder des vidéos pour vous divertir
mais surtout la grosse particularité
cette machine c'est qu'elle vous permet
de piloter votre smartphone alors l'idée
c'est pas le tournage ils regardent peut
être mon smartphone c'est cool c'est
beau non
l'idée c'est le partage le partage dans
le nu écosystèmes l'écosystème complet
huawei whaou continue à développer son
écosystème l'année dernière je l'avais
déjà présenté avec un macbook
de quelle manière il arriva comme unité
entre le pc et le smartphone live au
bond
plus loin en ayant un côté miroir votre
smartphone est directement intégrée de
votre ordinateur
comment ça marche je pense que vous
allez pouvoir en faire vous allez voir
s'en trouve de jolies horizon première
chose il vaut votre ordinateur de huawei
buffo votre macbook des casses pouces ou
quatorze pouliches que vous pouvez
gagner d'ailleurs n'oubliez pas le lien
est dans la description il vous faut
bien évidemment smartphones de huawei
est uniquement un smartphone de huawei
ou un smartphone de au nord ici le
pétrole pro sera parfaitement la faire
et dans votre ordinateur vous êtes dans
le logiciel qui s'appelle pc manager qui
me permettra de collecter extrêmement
facilement alors pour vous connecter
c'est très facile déjà ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que pour le partage de
fichiers un petit peu standard 1 29 ans
honor 9 la liste d'ailleurs est présente
sur le site de web mais si vous voulez
sur le partage d'écran et bien il faut
un mec 30,1 et devint impétrantes un
honneur 20 il vous faut une machine en
gros un peu plus performante ce qu'il
faut que vous fassiez vous cliquez ici
sur connexion vous allez ensuite me
repositionner votre smartphone sur la
partie nfc je prends mon smartphone je
le positionnent comme ça ça me propose
ici de me connecter bien évidemment
j'autorise et c'est comme ça que la
magie opère et que je vois l'écran de
mon smartphone s'activer et voyez je
peux bien navigué complètement d'un côté
et de l'autre
qu'est ce que je peux venir faire
directement ici et bien sûr venir
naviguer très facilement dans mon
smartphone j'ai par exemple naviguer ici
extrêmement facilement sur instagram je
peux venir en plus poster directement
une photo sur instagram une photo bien
sûr qui sera dans mon smartphone et non
pas dans mon ordinateur parce que oui
effectivement je n'ai que ce que j'ai
dans mon smartphone ici que vient bien
évidemment consulter les sms passer un
coup de fil mais uniquement depuis mon
smartphone fera par exemple mais free
bird 3 pour pouvoir téléphoner
sinon ça sera directement avec le micro
du smartphone et uniquement avec le
micro du smartphone je peux venir
naviguer sur internet télécharger
différentes applications sur mont pelé
store consulter mon calendrier
tout ce que je peux faire dans mon
smartphone je le fais directement ici
toutes mes applis jacques ses atouts
c'est le seul principe c'est rigolo mais
la vraie idée derrière c'est pas
effectivement de se dire tiens je vais
naviguer d'un bon smartphone depuis mon
ordinateur parce que c'est pas
extrêmement intuitif
l'idée c'est de se dire que si vous
travaillez sur votre ordinateur vous ont
fait de faire du traitement de texte
vous bossez à la fac où que vous soyez
et bien vous allez pouvoir malgré tout
répondre à un sms directement depuis
clavier votre ordinateur et en plus ce
qui est extrêmement mal hein c'est par
exemple si vous êtes étudiant mais s'il
est en cours les smartphones sont
interdits vous synchronisez vous
planquer votre smartphone vous avez
quand même pouvoir venir tchatter depuis
votre smartphone sur instagram mail
envoyé des sms que vous voulez
directement depuis votre ordinateur et
sa personne le verra à la fin
donc ça c'est plutôt rigolo mais par
exemple s'en va aller beaucoup plus loin
il est en train de travailler sur votre
ordinateur et que vous voulez venir
partager directement l'information
ailleurs ce que vous faites ce que vous
faites hop vous venez copier ici vous
venez ensuite ici et vous venez le
collet ce qui fait que vous faites
exactement se couvrir la joue mon sens
côté sms vous pouvez venir le faire
directement sur du traitement texte pour
tout ce que vous voulez et c'est
extrêmement simple
donc là je vous montre le multi screen
je vous laisse imaginer tout ce que vous
pouvez en faire après mais un autre qui
est vachement intéressant et que j'avais
commencé à vous montrer les dernières
saisons watyah parce que huawei cher ça
vous permet de partagez extrêmement
facilement des informations des fichiers
des photos des documents depuis votre
ordinateur vers vos smartphones et
depuis votre smartphone vers votre
ordinateur par exemple et si je suis
dans l'application wps office où je vais
avoir tous me documenter je vais vouloir
transférer un document de mon smartphone
directement vers mon pc je sélectionne
jouve le document ici alors
effectivement il a pas grand mirroring
mais par contre il n'est pas
d'ordinateur si je veux qu'il y soit je
croise ici mon smartphone sur l'icône
huawei cher le transfert se fait le
document est transféré dans mon
ordinateur et je retrouve ici
alors ça ça marche dans un sens que
transférer un point d'eau qu'un point ce
que je veux mais tu peux le faire
également dans l'autre sens du coup ici
je retrouve avec un document où j'écris
ça coucou ce site un joli document word
qui sert pour faire un test pour faire
c'est qu'on va transférer depuis mon
ordinateur vers mon smartphone
directement posé mon smartphone sur
l'icône huawei cher ça va le reconnaître
je me positionne bien en face et ça va
me transférer ployer g l'icône world et
je me retrouve avec mon document lors
c'est écrit en tout petit ici coucou
ceci est un joli document word qui sert
pour faire un test
on peut donc transféré très facilement
tous les documents que ce soit dans un
sens ou dans l'autre
des documents des photos tout ce qu'on
veut on peut venir piloter extrêmement
facilement son smartphone depuis son
ordinateur grâce aux nouveaux macbook
des 15 moi je trouve plutôt intéressant
de tout cas ce que ça montre c'est
vraiment une fois de plus cette
connectivité globale cet écosystème
global chez huawei vous a effectivement
du smartphone vous avez l'ordinateur
vous avez vos buzz tout autre musique
vous connecter tout ça à votre monde
connecté en wi enfin l'écosystème et là
il est complet il est bien il est
intéressant ça va dans le bon sens je
vois vraiment l'évolution de la dernière
entre le tout début de huawei cher et ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui le fait d'avoir une
maison règne de son smartphone sur son
ordinateur
c'est une fois de plus un paquet fait en
avant ils font ça vraiment bien il
manque un truc par exemple à ce que vous
prouver
du côté de chez apple entre un macbook
et un iphone parce que vous allez
recevoir un appel sur votre iphone vous
allez pouvoir répondre de votre
ordinateur
ici c'est pas le cas vous allez voir
effectivement décroché mais par contre
on utilisera pas le micro et les hauts
parleurs de votre ordinateur mais bel et
bien ceux de votre marque foton qu'il
vous faut soit un kit mains libres pour
pouvoir prendre la peine soit mettre le
haut parleur
ce qui dans l'absolu est pas mal mais
pas complètement top up pour un peu
négatif pas un moment j'ai eu un petit
l'agp à un moment pas tout le temps de
temps en temps j'avais un peu de lag une
perte de connexion entre mon smartphone
et mon ordinateur c'est arrivé
occasionnellement mais c'est arrivé
en tout cas je trouve ça plutôt bien ça
va dans le bon sens ce qui est sûr c'est
scherwey c'est que l'innovation est là
ils sont vraiment des leaders dans
l'innovation quelle que soit la
typologie device alors bien évidemment
ce macbook des 15 également sur le dé 14
ans l'essor du milieu de gamme donc on
va pas voir ce qui se fait de mieux en
terme de spec c'est parce qu'on va venir
chercher non plus il est par contre le
fait pouvoir faire tout communiqué
moisson c'est vraiment cool ça direct à
vous pouvez trouver au tarif de 699
euros qui entraient commande je vous ai
mis un lien en bas dans la description
ballesta petit coup d'oeil moi les gens
trouvent plutôt intéressante jolie
machine qui ne sera pas destiné à tout
le monde
il faut vraiment qu'ils correspondent
aux usages que je vous ai décrit dans la
vidéo mais si c'est le cas vous pouvez y
aller parce que la machine est vraiment
cool
et si en plus vous avez un smartphone au
nord ou à louer une dernière génération
et bien vous allez vous faire plaisir
sur ce je vous invite à lire tout ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
comment vous trouvez ordinateur qu'est
ce que vous pensez que ce système nommé
rory de votre smartphone sur votre
ordinateur
mark et moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire mais surtout en devenant dès
demain ont continué par effect grand
prix isu à demain
[Musique]
ces bons qui des abonnés